how's it going back ma well jump to I
want to be the guy Gaiden playing with
this it's gonna be cool
it's another Rach game yeah
please select the stage all right what's
up I know there's a guy here because I
act box can I start the [ __ ] dick you
know it's gonna be a good game when you
died seven times before you even select
the [ __ ] elbow [ __ ] you why does he
come twice Oh what's up my name what's
[Music]
really [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] when
the pills be able to play no wonder
[ __ ] nose [ __ ] you whatever the [ __ ]
you are let's fire to play shed whoa wha
well am I am i controlling this hey guys
what's going on
I can't I hate that there's no emulators
I can't like cheetah [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa whoa
whoa I replayed I'm so dumb
chop chop
[Music]
don't do all that all that I can do this
dress I can do this
muchachos but you're way back are you
when they I can't hear you grab that
[Music]
Chad grabbed walls
it's fine I'm not I'm not even that
angry honestly
[Applause]
[Music]
get up [ __ ] ooh law yo what's up all
right everything could kill you be
gentle with me
[Music]
are you [ __ ] serious I don't I guess
it's just that you don't gonna cut it
out for you but you don't have to
experience this [ __ ] 30 second intro
every [ __ ] time cat Mario ain't got
[ __ ] [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
[Music]
and I got this face
I'm not angry how am I supposed to yeah
I mess was around nerd
[Music]
oh you got case
I blessed
replay I'm a [ __ ] dick [ __ ] that's
a bad word but hey I don't care anymore
well this game is fun wow I'm so amazed
by this game hey yeah let's make a game
by eventual ass for 30 seconds the men
will have shifted don't Kelly don't kill
me don't kill me don't kill me it's not
the same it's that that [ __ ] oh I
feel good now I don't have to do that
intro anymore
thank you a game he wanted to kill me I
can tell
[ __ ] you face [ __ ] you I'm your mama oh
you have a mama I don't care I love
grapple that [ __ ] nod reflect what the
hell are you doin what the [ __ ] was that
I wasn't even on that I sad
yes no what do you want from me a fish
[ __ ] go down fishing [ __ ] you nuts twice
why do you [ __ ] me twice [ __ ] yo fish eh
[ __ ] yo and your momma oh oh you think
you're [ __ ] clever now don't you you
[ __ ] dick got to go ahead we gotta go
falling we gotta suck a dick
[Music]
I broke my controller I chased recording
and it's a lot faster now at least you
know like at that I don't like this give
me slow down place this you're so
[ __ ] fast what how how did it happens
how and how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
it now No what am I supposed to do what
am I suppose it I don't don't dead limbs
daba daba daba daba Doo I'm inventing Oh
are they just get aside let's get it now
let's get a nice go on oh damn [ __ ] wake
and oh oh come soon and suck my dick I
let Dalbar we go in here
[ __ ] your fishing [ __ ] your fishy hi
these vans are gonna [ __ ] kill now
Jeff
what what what [ __ ] I'm enjoying this
[ __ ]
oh I think it's how much fun yeah okay
I do done diddly new do not [ __ ] like
this what do I do here what am I
supposed to grapple it back oh oh okay
[ __ ] well progress I'm happy I like
[ __ ] progress
[ __ ] you fit this [ __ ] interest is
part is the dick I've ever [ __ ]
[ __ ] I have not to [ __ ] the dick I'm
just [ __ ] being rich why does he kill
me when I jump over his I don't [ __ ]
get it
come on ma go eat a dick I like this
tiny bang go
[Music]
what's up
check out the world [ __ ] Jets what am I
supposed to do up here oh there's
something over there oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
gotta charge it oh I'm not gonna make it
if I make it I will kiss you you don't
want it I don't give a [ __ ] for dads
[Music]
hey man there's a pathetic I didn't [ __ ]
me nose your lady who everybody
suggested me this [ __ ] game yeah ha
ha ha Thank You Sasha your decks there
we go
[Music]
not angry Oh hola hola Liz gave yourself
troll you hahaha so funny how about it
why the [ __ ] Nina oh well I know I
could do that [ __ ]
alright here it comes
clap for me brass knob a girl can't flap
egg cut the wrong [ __ ] muscle match
ok were made Hybris once again
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that was my says that that's good
and I'm feeling better now god I'm gonna
have dinner with them now good good that
I know Italian so I can explain what the
[ __ ] I was doing
this game just [ __ ] [ __ ] to me I was
having dinner and sometimes my says and
isn't with us and I don't even [ __ ]
care anymore basically I couldn't
explain what the why I was yelling and
touching my face I weighed it was just
almost awkward dinner ever because I
don't speak Italian and Mazdas pants
doesn't speak English thank you game I
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you [ __ ] me that's
what happened
alright okay
various there's the same come on don't
be jealous
place it down check it out dad I prize
[Music]
101 what do you watch
I'm run it mama but as you want
why does he all right
[Music]